Today we are going to look at.
an application of deep learning
and neural networks for image
classification
so we are going to look at the
Keras Library, which is
You know a library that abstract
some of the complexities of tensorflow.
And during a process of building this
model.
we will also make references to
The Matrix
operations
so we will today see what kind of evolution is. What a
a filter is and what is pooling Matrix
or a pulling tensor today?
We'll talk about the concept of tensors as well.
So, let me write down the agenda.
We are going to create a new notebook.
Jupiter notebook, of course four
image classification
and that sometimes somewhere halfway through the notebook in
order to understand what it is that we're actually coding.
I'll switch to vs code where
I can show you the mathematics.
so we want
discuss Matrix kind of evolution
it will be more accurate to say tensor convolution because a
matrix is a general.
object
for a vector
a tensor is a general object for
a matrix.
So vectors A type of tensor a matrix
the type of tensor.
We will see what that is. I'll show you visually what it is as well
Matrix convolution.
a filter
and
Cooling
talk about pulling is
and then if time allows it.
We want to talk about classification metrics.
Now there are different classification Matrix. We
will talk about the one that we will be using today. By the
way. There is an upcoming Workshop.
on the 28th of July
It's about this is the second
episode of ml papers.
And we'll be about the ROC metric.
It's a very important Matrix that receiving operating characteristic.
So we'll be a good.
That will be a more in depth.
tutorial about classification
so
hopefully you'll find that useful and you'll be able to attend.
Okay, let's begin. Let's begin with this.
It's only three. I mean it's three items but
this it will take up the entirety of today's session. So let
me switch right away.
and
I do recommend you type along.
You don't need to download the data set externally everything is
going to be contained.
inside the notebook
so you can just go to colab.
I'll paste the link.
here in Zoo
And this I believe should be tutorial
70.
Okay.
The first we will go ahead and import.
our libraries
We have tensorflow.
we have
Keras so tensorflow
actually want to say from tensorflow. We want to import the
following items.
the data sets
the layers
and the models
and
You want to visualize our metrics that we will import and visualize the
data set?
Some of the data some of the pictures this
data citizens is a set of pictures.
Matt
plot lip dot Pi plot
as PLT
for those of you this session we're able to see that video.
That I referenced.
or
Adam the atom algorithm
Okay, great.
so
the next thing we want to do is import our data set.
from the data sets object
I will use the method.
load data, so C4 10
C410 dot load data,
let me show you what c410 is the database of pictures?
Small pictures and they are all
uniform in size.
Now this method will return.
training images testing images accompanied by
their labels
If these are terms with which you are not familiar, I will explain
them to you in a moment.
so we have
a train images
and the train labels
test images
test labels
Well this downloads. Let me show you the C4 database. This
is it.
Here we go.
It is a data set that contains 60,000 pictures.
That are only 32 by 32.
all color
And all of these 60,000 pictures fall into
one of ten classes.
Here are focuses.
the fundamentals of neural networks, so
Once we covered this.
Example and we understand.
what the
why we
have this particular architecture now a new electron people
will then be able to well build upon what we know?
And then we can work with other pre-trained models
or even come up with our own models so
we can go to research papers.
and they will make reference to different types
of
neural network layers, but once we have a foundational
understanding we can
create our own architecture and make
sense of
those research papers
Sorry, these are some of the pictures they're very small 32 by
32.
Okay. Well, we're gonna train a model
that is that will be able to classify pictures like
so like the ones you're saying here.
And they all have certain characteristics. So for example the subject.
Of the picture is in the center of the
picture like this car this bird.
this bird
this
these deers
moose
You don't have any of these into Pie by the way.
so like
Elks there we go.
What do we call the class of such creatures deers who's elk?
I think most are quite large right there. I think that the
largest of
their type
but yeah.
all of these big
pictures have the object one in the center.
So the more all of that we are going to build or train can
only
accurately classify pictures of this
nature
Square
in size
And the subject is clearly right in the
center. And of course it belongs to one of these same classes. So if you if
you want to predict, let's say
a
I don't know.
A basketball or a
person?
They will not be able to do so.
or what I will do well when we see it's not going to be able to do so it's going to
Put them into the class that is closest.
Or the class that is most probable.
which will be incorrect anyway, but again, this is
the point here is not to create a
Production level machine learning model, but just
to understand the fundamentals here, okay.
But return here now that the data set has
been downloaded.
Let me it's right now in the environment. So I don't think
it will appear here in the files and folders.
So it's actually they are downloaded into the
memory the temporary storage of the computer.
the instance on Google Cloud
So if I were to type in LS?
by the way in colab
You are able to.
Work with two programming languages and of course markdown markdown,
we don't call a program with language if you want to
work with the best script you put you put in a percent.
And this exclamation mark tells colab
that what follows after the exclamation mark
will be bash script.
So we can use the LS.
Command to list.
The contents of what we have just downloaded.
Or actually the contents of this folder.
Okay.
What we want needed in this example, though.
Let's carry on.
then we have
the images in the form of a tensor
so if you remember by the way you tensorflow is
built on top of numpy
so
data will be for will be stored in the form of a numpy.
Object and if you remember we said that a numpy
object as three attributes
and the data.
So one of those attributes is shape.
And here by shaping me this shape of the tensor.
so
I want you to imagine.
A tensor to be a collection of matrices. Let me show
you a picture here.
There's a glory that I have created.
in
Word document
which I will share with you as well.
Let me just because I have the picture in there. Oh Siri.
I mean you can put you can see this picture and Google but I
want to show you the one I found.
glossary
There we go.
So for
tensor
Yeah.
This is a tensor.
It's a stack of matrices.
But it can also be a stack.
of columns
so you can
arrange it. You can arrange a stack of
matrices horizontally or laterally or
in in this frontal arrangement
so let's try to imagine our
tensor of pictures to be this so here.
What I return you when I bring you back the notebook it says
here what?
It says 50,000.
32 3 what do we mean by this? We have
50,000 pictures.
and
pictures that are 32 by 32 with three color
channels
That's what this means.
And this could be this is one tensor.
so
it's a sequence of tensors.
For each image is a stack of three three
color channels.
Okay.
Let's return.
Let me look up the remaining code I have here.
And the next thing I want to show you.
okay, also for the test now, of course the data
set that we
downloaded has 60,000 images here. It
says fifty thousand. Where are the remaining 10? Well they are.
in the test data set
Again, what is the what's the purpose of training test?
Maybe quickly also pull up this other Slide the slide from
our last Workshop.
Tell you about test.
And train and sometimes something called validation.
Okay.
train test and validation
if you remember.
from our last session we talked about
the multi-- the perceptron
it was this mathematical model, but we
had these features.
and with each feature was associated with
let me actually pull it pull that up.
By the way, we all create another slide
later on and
Take the relevant slides and put them in.
in the new slide
because not all of this is relevant to
our course
here
if you remember we showed we talked about this very fundamental component
of a neural network.
So it has
you know.
these inputs
and each input corresponds to
a feature of the dataset
So again to use a real estate example the features
of a property.
It's the number of bedrooms the number of bathrooms.
the size of the apartment
And these are the weights now in machine learning
terminology. We also
called these.
parameters
So wait parameters. These are the same thing.
Parameters and weights refer to the same thing.
So here
the purpose of the training data set
is to let the model learn the parameters to understand.
To understand, you know, it's all.
statistical calculation
but we want the monitor calculate the weights. Now
if you have a regression problem the way
you find the weights.
Will you there's something called the Computing formula?
Again, it's nothing more than basic arithmetic. Maybe
we can talk about the later on.
But it has to do with the observations and the residuals.
And the residual is a distance of the observation from the regression
line. If you've watched the video from that,
I referenced you would be familiar
with these terms anyway in the training stage. We want
the model to learn the parameters.
Sometimes training and validation is done in one.
in one go
So depending on the library that you're using in the machine learning while they're
using you may have to create you may need to have three
divisions. So you will take your original data and divide
it to three.
Training validation tests other times you can
just have trained and test.
the purpose of validation
is to see the check the metrics to
identify underfitting overfitting.
We said that underfing underfitting is when the model has
not been able to calculate the
Which properly and you can easily detect this because as
soon as you look at the metrics.
Let's say we talked about MSC if the MSC
is large. It is diverging from
zero for the train that asset that's under 30. So we
don't go any further. We don't even proceed to test.
So if that happens.
then
we'd have to adjust our data or just our
machine learning model.
And that is if we can even do something
about it because sometimes the data is so sparse. So
Unusable, there's not much you can do about
it.
You know the same garbage and garbage out.
So we need to make sure there's no garbage.
but
another purpose of validation is for the model to
adjust the parameters after it has learned.
So after it learns the parameters.
Even if the metrics are good, let's say MSE is
good.
We want it to be better still.
So in this validation stage with the
validation data set.
We can we look at the metrics and then if necessary we
up. We change the hyper parameters now do not.
Conflate parameters in hyperparameters. Unfortunately, there's
one library at least that I S skater very
popular Library.
They use these two words interchangeably or
at least when I look at the documentation that is the
case. That's a problem because
hyper parameter parameters are different things very different
things. The parameters are the weights that the model must learn.
the hyperparameters
Are like the arguments of
the function?
so we will have
let's say a machine learning class like sequential and
the sequential class can take different arguments. We will
see this in a minute.
You as the data scientist must choose the hyper parameters.
They're effectively arguments of a function. So you must
change the architecture of the neural network.
If in the case of deep learning until you know, we
get a better combination. So as the machine learning if you're doing machine under
two things you need to fix.
Or two things you need to take into account the
date the quality of the data.
and the type of machine learning model you choose
you've chosen and the
The configuration so actually that's a better
word for hyperparam is the configuration.
hyperparameters equals configuration of the
model
now
In order for you to find out.
if this model
is
Usable and can be put into production after the
best possible.
configuration after the best possible data
mudging that imagining is a nobody clean the data.
You do feature engineering. So assuming you've done
you've you've picked the best possible model and you have so
you have reduced the best possible data if
this model is going to be useful or not, and that is used
to test data set.
the test dataset
After test essay, we'll check the metrics after the adjusted model after
the adjusted parameter after the model has learned the new parameters.
So after the test data set your metrics are still poor then.
The model is not the it's not the right option.
That is assuming your data is
you know well
You know, your data is in the best possible condition.
So if that's the if that's the case and your model is still
pulled and you need to choose a different model. Either that or again you need
to check the hyper parameters. So if you find overfitting here.
Then you must go back.
to
what comes before the training stage?
Okay.
So in our case, we just need training and test.
The training dataset would allow them all
to learn the parameters and the test set I said we will see if we have
underfitting overfitting.
Or if we are on the right track.
Okay.
So we have 50,000 images for training
10.
images for test
now let me
show you some of the pictures. I mean, we just saw it in
the
on the website, but
we want to make it part of our notebook.
So here let me add some sections to this notebook.
this is
import
libraries
and data
Let's call this point one.
and then this will be
part 2
review
the data
so we said that c410 has
10 classes.
Sorry.
And what we want to do is plot.
a grid of
a grid of 10 pictures
and then when a loop over 25 samples
And then Plateau so we will say.
or
I in range.
The range function will create a sequence of numbers.
So here we want from 0 to 25.
And I will say PLT Dot subplots.
and
this is index.
We want we don't we this is not a Cartesian or
any kind of coordinate system. So we're going to empty out
the
like remove any labels from the plot
So we'll pass your empty list.
Save for the y axis.
We don't want any grid.
again, because this is not a
coordinate system
and then we want to impose the picture or superimpose the picture.
Well from each class.
So we have train.
images
and then we want to say yeah, I want to
put the
class label of each picture and on the x-axis like stable.
class names
train
labels
So if I show you the train labels?
up here
It's going to be a list within a list.
So if you want to preview a particular class.
we will need to go inside the list first and then
Get the scale of value.
So that's what we have.
to set the square brackets
So what we once we run this code, this is what we should see.
No, this is not what we should see.
What did I leave out?
I think for this third argument it
needs to be.
My plus one.
and
it's a plot singular.
and then I am
I am sure.
There we go.
So again the picture we just saw but it's a good
idea to have them here and our notebook.
Okay.
next
we want to create our neural network.
So let me
Write the code first.
I will then take the slide to show you.
the picture of the architecture and then
I'll show you the
The Matrix operation we call
Carnival evolution
So this is going to be called.
building the
neural network model
so we will instantiate the sequential class like
we saw in the previous notebook.
again, because we again because we are critic a
sequence of
layers input layers and layers
output layer
of course, we can stack onto the stock other types of layers, but we're
just going to have
we will have two convolutional layers three convolution layers.
two Max pooling layers
One Flat layer
and two
dense layers
What are these we'll see in a minute.
So we have
the input layer
We have one con
2D layer.
all about a Max pool layer
And we will do this three times.
flat layer
and two dense layers
This is the architecture.
Let me show you a picture of it.
Now, I don't think if I don't think the one I have here is the
same architecture, but it doesn't really matter if
you understand what these components are.
and what they are used for that's
that was suffice.
Where is that picture?
This is the one.
So we are building something of this sort.
This one has two card layers that one has three.
And this one has two bags pull layers double so.
Okay, that one also has okay. So actually it is
this one.
It is this one. So this is the first convolution layer.
Okay. So this one it just has one convolution layer less
and one density or less. Anyway, the point is this.
we will use the convolutional layers which are just
stack of matrices or tensors
to represent this picture in all of its
three color channels.
Then we're going to use a Max pool.
to
and something that is not visualized here something that is
not plotted here and not even there.
Is the kernel?
Let me double check that.
Do we have a kernel in here?
Yes, but it's not it's not it's not.
It's part of the convolution here. So there's a there's a
matrix inside kind of 2D layer,
which is called the the filter. So it's not visualized.
You're although it should have been that would have been more clear, but it's
one Matrix convolved with another Matrix and
the result of that Matrix. Well then be
pulled
inside this other Matrix
the idea here is to
contain the important.
activations from this Matrix
so
Let's keep this picture in mind. Let me take you to.
Vs code to show you what a convolution is first.
Okay.
We're going to create a Newton markdown file.
Let's call this.
math tutorial
question does each layer in the first convolutionary
have its own kernel? Yes.
All three will have will have
filters. Yes.
Let me show you what they are very easy and simple concept
by the way.
So I will call this.
Let's call it neural networks.
So we have first a convolutional layer.
and we'll talk about
filter
and then we will talk about
pooling
of which there are two types. There's average pooling and
Max pooling.
So suppose we have and here.
I'm going to write some math from this
book.
this by the way
I know I promise to share the list of books.
But let me just point this out now because I have it here.
This is one of the best.
Written books on machine learning and especially neural
network just this one.
Muhammad Zaki
data mining machine learning
I mean this book is just
Pleasant to read
The book gradually built on.
basic concepts and work suits real
I highly recommend you get this book.
Either when physical form or digital form, so let
me show you the center the way they use
the notation here.
or convolution
we'll begin with a one-dimensional convolution and then we can
extend that idea to a two-dimensional.
Matrix
So suppose
we have two vectors.
I'm going to slightly adapt adapter writings here.
Can you write the name of the book? Yes the name of the book by the
way, I have these references here, right? So
I will add it here to number 10.
This is Mohamed Zaki.
Is the other more authors?
Yes.
and Mira
data mining
And the Machine and learning?
So Blue Book, yeah.
Okay.
and this is from
page
So suppose we have two vectors.
Now a picture is a matrix, but let's begin with one dimensional first.
with the
components, you know x sub 1
x up to etc, etc.
And we have a filter Matrix of
excuse me. We talked about the vectors. This is
one dimensional for now.
so in one dimension
on
Lucian
Now this book uses w.
because a
while we are convolving it with with a filter.
Vector or a filter Matrix the components of
a filter Vector of filter Matrix are really weights. So it
makes sense. I will also use the same convention. We'll make
this w
and it will be weights.
Now what you need to know, is that the number of
components?
or the dimension of the weight
and features
are not the same.
And here's I'll write down
the mathematical notation, but then I'll show you pictures. It's very
simple concept.
Now we denote a kind of evolution with an
asterisk.
So we take our two vectors X and W, of course
one of them has to be transposed.
So which one is transposed?
Okay, we don't need to transpose it.
But here's the idea.
We will perform an element wise operation on
the components of both vectors. So we
have
x sub k
i
And then I think this is ODOT.
Yeah.
and
w
so this dot inside the circle is the
element wise operation. What we are going to do is we will
take
let's say
now x sub K refers
to
a
section of the vector
Let me show you let me show you let me show it to you here.
I think I even have it in that slide.
Do I have it in the slide? I think I do.
If not,
I will draw draw. It's it's not that difficult to
explain.
No.
Let me show you let me show you the book. Let me
show you a picture of that book. Sorry, I should have downloaded this before. Let me
I'll do it quickly.
exactly
There we go. Page 694, right?
let me go to that page.
6 9 4
show you convolution now convolutions also applied to
functions, but we're not going to get it there right now.
It's going to load any second now.
Come on.
It's big book. That's why it takes a while to download. Let me
try again.
the work
finally
And it's okay for me to show you this picture page because the author
actually made the slides many parts
of this page available online for free.
iOS, try to find
The link I think if we Google Zaki you
the website will show up.
So I look up the slides the slides are quite helpful.
I mean the author did a tremendous job of
explaining these Concepts pictorially. Yeah, so this
is the cover of the book.
Now, let me jump to that section.
so
it's the numbers are not.
Correct.
So I need to scroll to six
nine four.
There we go. So this is our Vector. Yes. This is what I
mean by sub.
section of the vector
so if your filter is one by
three vector
what you are going to do?
Is do an element wise.
multiplication so one times one
three times zero
one times negative 2
and then the sum of that.
Same thing here.
three times one
two times two. So three times one is three times two is four.
Obviously the zero cancels this other one out so it gets
seven.
Now if you notice here, there's a fourth
term.
the term stride
A stride is how many well strides you're taking?
In the vector like how many strides if imagine
this is your vector?
This your vector. How many strides are you going? Like how many?
Components are you skipping?
I mean, it's pretty clear in this picture here. The stride is one.
So initially the window if the filter was multiplying
this first three components and
then we take a one strike down.
And then we do an element wise operation.
And then we continue this way until we've covered the entire.
vector
this is the product.
Or the result of this kind of evolution operation.
And this is what that notation is representing when
I say x for example, except One X up to x sub
3.
Okay.
So X of three is the number of components your multiplying
this corresponds the three the subscript
code response to the size of the filter here.
Don't know by w.
so the first subsection the second subsection third subsection
and you are going to
add
The result of this element wise operation. That's what you're seeing
here. So this sum
is that value this sum is that
value and so on and then you will sum
up all of these together.
So you're going to add up?
negative 1 7 5 4 negative 1
and this will be put into another Matrix. So if I
can scroll down here.
Let me jump to and show you the 2D version. So this is 2D
convolution.
Right here.
There we go. Same idea.
This is applicable to what we are doing.
Okay.
again
Even in this example we're going in strides of
one.
So multiply element-wise right the order.
Well and notice this is an identity Matrix.
So which means the numbers on the
principal diagonal of this subset?
Will be What Remain and they will be added together. So one times
one?
two times zero is going to cancel out three times zero is going to cancel out
one times one add these together you get to
Then we take one story to the right.
So we are looking at the picture
so to speak by taking a strike you're scanning
the picture.
And the numbers we the there was a
and the numbers you would pick in the weights depend.
On how you want to look at the picture because for a
model to look at a picture.
Or is to look at vertical lines
or horizontal lines or diagonal
lines.
So if you look so that's why we have multiple filters because we
want to look at the picture from different. Let's say
angles and then add up everything. We see
everything the model sees.
Same thing here two times one.
That's two it's sorry two times one is
two four times one is well four.
So four plus two is six there's zeros.
Eliminate one. I think you get the idea, right?
And of course we can then take this and do this for us to a tensor,
which is a stack of matrices.
I think this is the picture for it.
But I think you get the idea.
Okay.
And then we have Max pooling. So let me return the notes
Here.
We will take this sum.
of all of these so
I will use.
Which notation helps the best?
Just going to put some here.
Okay.
That's all the kind of Illusion is.
the filter
Is that W vector?
so
where
X
Is the data?
And the data can be anything pictures.
sequence of
words
prices
Like in the real estate example and W is the filter.
Now what is a filter?
Let me show you a picture because that's the best fastest way
to make sense of a filter. So I'm gonna go I we
think we saw this in perhaps in our
first session.
I will look it up again. So I'm gonna type here.
neural network
filter image
horizontal vertical
yeah, this is it. By the way this example I
believe is from another very well written book.
I know I keep saying this is what the other one is
the I'll show you in a second. But here you
can obviously see we have this number four. Yes.
now in order for the model to perceive
The number four it must be able to see.
the vertical lines
the horizontal lines and
diagonal lines if any
If you see here we have how many vertical lines
we have two vertical lines?
this part of the number four
and obviously this part of the number four.
And then the one horizontal line.
Is here?
So we will have one filter.
For the vertical lines that is how we will arrange now. They
don't have they haven't shown you the combination. Like
how what numbers would you put in the filter?
But
I'll show it to you in a minute.
Anyway, so this will be a matrix the filter Matrix.
And when you convolve this Matrix
with the original Matrix, you can
see we'll get the we will get these signals.
So you can see here. We have the number three.
Three is a very strong signal.
and two
is a strong but not as strong. But anyway, we the
model has perceived is able
to see those two lines.
So they this part corresponds to that
and by the way, why is this three? Well, because when
we took a stride here, we saw three when
you take a stride here.
The signal weakens and when you come
down here the signal weakens even some more.
Right because it's affected by these zeros.
and then
yeah.
These are all three but because we have a completely
white pixels.
all the way from top to bottom
same thing here for the horizontal lines.
There are there is not a horizontal line so to
speak because but there is some.
Activity, but it's not strong enough to constitute a
lot which is why the signal is weak up here.
Here, however, we have would you have a strong signal?
But you have these twos because they're affected by
these zeros.
And then we have no vertical lines. Excuse me. We
have no highs enter lines in this part of the Matrix which is why the
signal is completely weak.
But if you try to visualize this if you were to
put these two matrices together.
If you were to put these Matrix if I would like to take this three.
And bring it up here.
It would form the number four.
And there's nothing across the diagonal. So this is weak altogether.
That's the purpose of the filter.
Now the numbers you would choose in the filter that
really depends.
And I don't remember what numbers you have to put
like what weight you have to put specifically in the filter here. This is another good
good illustration.
Let me make it higher resolution.
This is a picture. Yeah, and you have different filters one for horizontal
line one for a vertical line one for this one for that
and you will convolve all these filters by
the original Matrix.
Okay.
Where was that web page? We looked at the other day. I think
he was on our first session. So
all Network
blog
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure we've seen this already.
Colonel is also synonymous with filter.
Okay.
So for example if you put a 5.
Sorry about that if you put a 5 in here.
in the middle
then and negative ones.
In these places, then you're going to sharpen the image.
so when you convolve
this picture with that.
Matrix
the effect will be to sharpen the image and you can see we get
a clear outline of the person's face where the
eyes are where the lips are. So this is
going to be easier to classify than the picture on the left.
Okay.
I can look at up and show you what numbers are
arranged in the filters. So for emboss.
You can see will be 2 1 0.
You get the idea, right? That's the point.
And then we have Max pooling.
Matrix
of weights to
I'll put a quotation marks perceive.
the
what's the what's a good word to use here?
to perceive the
outlines for example of the
picture
vertical line vertical
lights horizontal lines
question when doing it convolution is the output image always
smaller than the input image.
Well, yes.
Yes, because you are.
Well, I mean that's that's the that's
the effect of multiplying is a large
matrix by smaller Matrix. It will be smaller. Now what you can
do is
Now there are different types of new architecture where you can
actually blow up the picture.
Okay.
But let me show you what pooling is pulling is.
is very
You in the case of Max pooling. Let me go that book here.
Where's that book?
Pulling is when you take.
Which pages I think it's page 700 so.
Let me show you pulling.
here
Let me show you what Max cooling what pulling does
and then why would use pooling so here you can see when we have
this.
If this is a picture the super pixel or the sub sample
if the whole Matrix the sample then a sub
sample is a section.
You will take the strongest or the maximum
value in this in this particular section.
It's the number three.
In this section, it's the number four.
In this section is the number two.
And here it's 4 that's what Max pooling does.
Now Max pooling is done for two purposes.
the pooling
the pulling Matrix
in order to make this application
now Max pooling Matrix
is used to achieve.
following
one
reduce
the computational
load of computing
activations
You know like in the brain's neuron, right or the
perceptor we talked about the signal the travels down
the neuron we want to make it. Let's come or
something because this picture is a 32 by 32
pictures.
32.3 is a tiny picture.
When in reality?
The kinds of picture you would see on the internet are 300 by
300 500 by 5. If
you're using a DS if using dslrs or a mirrorless camera, like
the one I have in here.
There will be Million by million.
Like 13 million by 30 million.
so
and imagine you want to do this in real time. It will be very
demanding
and that's just for one picture. Imagine. We have like a folder of
pictures. So this Max pulley will really make it
easier to
figure out what's in the what's the picture?
The second part of Max pooling is to handle.
Or not let them use another word.
Two it is called translational invariance.
The word I want to use is what?
to
become
translationally invariant
And what this is what me?
Oh, there's another slide start over here based on
the Kernel side and the stride.
Yes, exactly. So the output will depend on the
size of the kernel.
and the stride
smaller stars are better, but they are more time consuming.
Does a maximal identify which kind of volusional curl in
the previously had the highest match?
That's Max pool identify which kind of evolutional.
Not the kernel.
The sub sample in The convolutional Matrix
and if I bring it back to the book.
it is not the kernel from
which the filter from which we're getting the
max value from the origin convolution
so for example if I bring you back this
here
Do you see this? Do you see this grid this red this
three by three red grid
So in this picture or in this corner?
Let's say we what we actually want dark colors because we want to
find out the outlines. So we want to discard the
white background and focus
only on the
outline the face. So here the strong signals will be the darker
pixels.
So you can see here in this three by three.
The largest value is the one at
the bottom right corner.
And then for example if I come here.
The strong mystical will be in the top left.
top lifter
corner
I hope that answers your question.
Again, the way you would arrange the numbers in the filter will depend
on the color Channel.
And what you are trying to detect if I scroll down here?
Let me show you what what habits this picture
when you apply different filters.
identity will obviously identity will give you
the same image, but for example if I put in
blur
you can see that it didn't work identity.
It's very subtle. Let me reduce the
numbers here
Miss playing around.
Darkness
it's very celebrated. It's blurred.
So I mean the numbers you would put in this in this
filter or kernel all depend on
what you're trying to do.
I guess there was another link here which we can look up.
Great.
Okay. Well, let me come back here. Let me come back to the
This point here. What do you mean by translationally invariant?
But we already saw translation back in module 2 when
we were
When we took that plane and
we applied shearing to it, but there is this nice presentation from
Harvard.
Which does a good job of explaining?
Or visualizing in variance. So let me
skip to that section.
Where are you?
Yeah, so these are the different types of filters you can use.
Again, we will use the word filter and kernel interchangeably. This is the identity. You
just put a 1 in here.
You get the same picture?
If you want add detection.
You can use these numbers.
Okay.
sharpen if you want to
a pre-process the data
Let me show you translation.
So is it not this one?
Okay.
It was a very nice slide here to explain translations.
I am pretty sure it was a
Basically, it's here. Let me show you Lydia translations.
Yeah, this is an example.
Simply when the picture is off center.
Here's another example.
We have different types of invariants, right?
Let's say in the c410 dataset.
The pictures are merely in the center, but they
can be a little bit off-center. Maybe the picture is
too big or something. Excuse me. The subject is too big.
Or the subject is too small or here if
it's maybe rotated so here for example, the subject is
in the center, but it's rotated. The max
pooling is meant for this purpose. It's them it's to make the model resilient.
to translations
This is size and variance see exactly
so we in some of the pictures and the c410 is
at the subject takes up the entire almost the
entirety of the picture in some cases. It's small.
Illumination, right? So it's the same object, but you can see because the light
Is being emitted from different angles it can
really change.
the content of the picture
that's what Max putting is used for.
So let me return here.
To our notebook. Let me finish up the code.
And to save time I'm just going to copy paste.
aligned
so first we have
we're going to add a carnival kind of illusional 2D layer.
This will act.
this
stack that we adding this kind of 2D.
Let me put them on strap online. So we know what these arguments are.
So this is for the input layer.
Which corresponds to the this dimensions of
the picture with height and color channels?
so input
of the model
we have with height and
number of color channels
This is the activation function and I guess
we haven't talked about this. We will just have to do it in the next session.
Activation function and I will show you the tensorflow playground.
If I showed you pictureally you will get
the point.
This is the size of the filter.
And this is this number of filters you have.
32 64
I'm graph filters.
So you can take any Carnival 2D layer.
And activate this argument input shape
and this will in fact become the input layer and
the first Carnival 2D layer.
Now we will use max pool Lee.
maxpool 2 dimensions
again, that's the size of the filter.
This is the size.
Excuse me.
This is the size of the
size of the max pulley
Matrix
Number of filters of the same number as kernels.
No, we use filters and curled interchangeably.
So what you're asking here is now is the number of photos the
same number of filters.
Filters and kernels we use interchangeably.
Okay.
And then we have another carnivore to kind of 2D layer.
So I'm going to copy paste.
Because what we want to do.
If I bring you back to this diagram.
We want to further.
convolve
the
max pool layer
with
the new representation of the picture
Let me see if I can show it to you here picture only.
convolution
to the
next
Let me see if I have it in the slides.
I mean basically it's this right. So if I bring you back
Let me try to explain to you this way.
imagine here
What was that?
the animation one
here
imagine what we do is we take our original picture.
and we use a
We convolved with the filter.
And then we get this outline image.
From this outline image we will get the maxport. We will
get the Strong's activations, but we still want to further.
identify the important
patterns in this picture
so
This is not exactly the max pool layer. But
imagine it is the max pool layer. What we
want to do is take this.
And further decompose it.
Because you can see in this picture.
It is clear that it is ahead at least to us, but it
can be clear or still.
So we can for example.
We have some.
Shade of green the forehead some Darkness on the
left side of the face some brightness of the dark side of
the face. So we want to cover this again Max pull
it to further to further, you
know, make it clear that this is a face and
even remove the background.
That's the point here.
Now the correct combination of how many Carnival 2D
layers you need how many Max pulley Max pool
layer. You need really depends on
experimentation
you would try this configuration first.
Look at the metrics. Is it good?
Perfect continue. Otherwise, you will go back and up change
the hyper parameters. So these are all.
These are hyper parameters that we have here.
The number of filtered you choose is one hyper parameter. The size
of the filter is another private parameter the size
of the structure. The number of strides is not a hyper parameter. So there are
some experimentation involved.
Okay. Anyway, let me go and copy this and finish this code because we
won't have 12 minutes left.
So conf 2D we then use max
pool again.
And then one more convolutional layer.
We don't need the max max pool here that we will flatten it.
actually, what flat does it from the slides and
in
from module 1
and then we have
softmax
I'm not sure we'll be able to talk about.
the the loss function which is
something called cross entropy
and for us to understand the soft Max.
activation function
we would need to talk cover some probability.
There's something called probability. There is something called the odds.
Which is the ratio of two probabilities?
So I guess we'll have to this either in the third session or
I'm just gonna have to record an extra tutorial because for the activation
function.
In particular softmax function and the
loss function there were about to use me. We need to cover some.
probability Theory
missing a parentheses
The reason we have this flat layer.
Is to turn this Matrix into one vector
where the vector will represent the distribution.
Remember, we said that a machine learning model?
Will we will not we did
not say that I did not say that in this course I said in a
separate.
tutorial
I put it in a total called
envelopes, which I have to put on the main Channel.
but
whether it's sound bites whether it's pictures, whether
it's characters, whether it's
clusters
no matter what the
Modality of the data if you remember we talked about the modality we
said there are different ways to perceive data sound
vision.
No matter what the modality of the data.
Ultimately, whatever the nature of
the data is it will turn into a distribution.
distribution is this
if you watch the video from yesterday, you would know what a distribution
let's say probability distribution.
Everything must ultimately turn into one of these.
and the shape of this
the shape of the distribute the word distribution really
means shape of the data.
So the shape of the data will determine what?
This thing is so for example if the distribution is
skewed, right?
It's skewed right when it when you have this downward this
tail that goes all to the right. So for example, let's
say if it's skewed right then it's a cat.
If it's centered, it's a car.
If it's bimodal, this is a bimodal distribution.
Like this. It's a truck.
So what the model really sees is this it
cannot see colors it cannot see words. It
cannot hear sounds what I can see is these distributions and
this is just
numbers that are plotted
I think we have to spend some time. I think we need this separatory
talk about distributions.
But let me just show you one more thing just to get my point
across with this flattened layer.
if I take us to our first
presentation
I think it was another presentation the ml
papers. Let me pull that up.
This is the one.
So this episode one episode two is gonna start.
On the 28th, by the way.
So in this Workshop I talked about
this.
So you have your image?
comes in three color channels
at the end of what we're gonna do is gonna flood it. This will become a distribution so
you can see here in the right.
We can see the distribution of colors.
But this cat will have a distribution. Let me see if I
can pull up another picture to explain what this is.
Because pictures, you know will make it it just make it
make it easy a lot easier to explain an idea.
distribution
of
a picture
a histogram is analogous to that but not exactly.
I don't think I'm gonna have any luck pulling fighting.
a direct
picture to distribution example
Okay, let me try to explain another way frequency.
distribution
of
income
Yeah, a number of filters is the number of okay, you ask this
question earlier? Yes, but one number of further is equal to number of
kernels.
No not here.
Okay, I will try to illustrate it.
This way, let me come
down here.
We could copy of this.
So you might be asking yourself. Why were you not
better prepared, which is a good question. The problem is with the
challenges.
Since we don't have any prerequisites this course.
We do making assumptions about what people know or don't
know.
So sometimes you have to improvise.
But imagine we have something like this.
right
I'll make it very straightforward.
Let's say the x-axis.
is the
Once I'd be able to have multiple shapes.
mmm
Like I said, what something were buy model
makes sense. Let me first draw the graph.
But I think of an example.
occur
yeah, let's say x is the
access corresponding to
the income of a person disposable income
of a person and the y-axis will correspond
to
time spent at a mall
You know, I am in Dubai so we have plenty of malls.
So naturally these are the examples that pop into my head.
time spent at malls
or money spent at malls
and on the x-axis
we have
I said income right? I said disposable income.
Except for this example, it would not be
the best.
What's another synonym for disposable
income?
experiment money
disposable money
Okay.
But yeah, fine cash.
You know what now? Let me use a
it's my example. I'm struggle struggling to make it work.
each
Mad money let's let's say
it's age, okay.
on the Lower Side, let's say we have
A teenagers like 15 and up. Here
we have.
those the middle
by the way, this should have been a little bit more.
It should have been more.
You know.
Why you're at the middle?
like so
money spent at
Location let's say we want to know what kind of location this
is.
Where those on the younger side of the age?
axis
And those the operating upper.
Higher end of the ajaxis both of
them have a sharp.
kurtosis kurtosis means the pig at the
top
So by looking at a distribution, like what kind of place do very young
like teenagers and more senior
people spend their money?
You would say well I would give the answer to shopping mall right teenagers have
nothing better to do.
Then go to a shopping malls.
spending their parents money
Maybe some of you know what I'm talking about.
and seniors, well, you know if they want to hang out and
Relax, they might.
if they retire they make
go and spend money at the mall or you
know, they're there.
They have savings or they've invested.
seniors have their houses paid for exactly, you know,
let's say they bought house or they
want a lottery or they make good Investments when
they were younger and now they
can afford to go to the mall and you know, enjoy themselves everybody else
has
You know, they don't have the time to do that. They don't have the
time. You don't have these luxury. Let's say this is Extreme example
Wow, what's another example we can
do something like this?
What could this location be?
Almost no teen it very few teenagers.
very few senior people
but a lot more of people, you know, let's say they're twenties
to fifties.
What do you think is kind and this is kind of skewed left. So older.
What possible place could this be?
It's a
guess. It's not an actual place.
Good grocery store. Very good. Yeah grocery store,
right?
I could be a couple or a
single parent has to break groceries
for the shop. So they would spend more time and money
there.
That makes perfect sense.
This is precisely what I'm talking about.
Everything whether it's a picture or numerical data
or a secular bytes will be turned to distribution. And that's what
the model will see.
on the x-axis we will have
the
the features
the y-axis would be
it will be for example duration.
or some sort of
it will be a numeric value and the numeric value could
either represent time spent on a place money spent
at a place or it could be an ID corresponding
to the class of that thing.
So the really the whole this whole point of me bringing you here
and taking your time with their slides was to explain
the purpose of having.
this
layer the flat layer we go from a matrix to Flat
layer because everything was turned
into distribution.
So all of these pictures that you see up here, they will all
have their own distinct fear distributions.
And that's it.
This dense layer then.
This one down here in particular.
is to give us the 10 possible classes to which the particular
picture belongs in order so
we will have
A the top 10 classes. We don't have 10
classes anyway, but it will give you the top 10 classes in order
of higher probability.
And that's it.
Now the remaining parts of this notebook which you know, I know it's already five minutes
past our schedule is really about
an example picture and
the
the classification function
Which is called.
category
excuse me chemical cross-entry
So we'll just leave us leave this for later.
And then just to make our last
session more interesting. Maybe I will show you other types
of I will definitely show you the tensorflow playground that is
very important and it's actually quite fun.
and
maybe we can look at other more advanced examples of
neural networks really if we understand.
If we understood these components.
You will be you'll be
able to put you would be able to understand any other type of architecture in
a research paper and implemented knowing what is
actually happening.
Now there are other more advanced.
architectures like recurrent neural networks
And while neural networks do have
vectors.
They're more elaborate than convolutional neural
networks.
I guess you can just do separate we can
have separate sessions outside of this this course.
Okay.
Now the less I'll give you an example of a book for I'll give
you this. I will give you the completed notebook. I'll give you
the RN and notebook.
But for RNs we would have to I we
definitely have to cover in a separate separate session in
a separate tutorial to ask what sort of updates does Google make
the tensorflow that makes updates not backwards compatible.
I ran into an issue with Keras. I came
across a nice notebook.
What they do is they deprecate.
certain objects or objects within
the library
or they may go from python 2 to Python 3.
Or they deprecated just take out they just
take out.
old methods
and replace it with nothing.
So, I mean it depends now.
I found out if you want to see all of the deprecated changes to
go to Keras on GitHub. This is what I found out.
You know, which methods were?
Deprecated and by the way, we can always you can
always downgrade. So if you find a notebook that is compatible with a specific version of
cares. You can always down great and make it work.
Keras
GitHub deprecated changes
Here we go. This is the one.
I'll put the link here in the chat as well.
Again, keros is built on tensorflow, by the way.
So yeah, you can go through these releases and see
what was removed.
Here, for example, they've added resnet.
Yeah, so right now I think the past you would
have to download resnet 50.
This is a pre-trained model now. It's just part of the applications object.
This was when April of this year.
Yeah.
To check that out.
But you can always on call lab. It's pretty sure for to it's pretty
straightforward to downgrade.
So if you found the nice example have a look at this.
and
there will be
that's all you do.
Okay everybody. Thank you very much for joining me today.
Okay more questions. Can you please show the preview data section
of the notebook?
preview section of the notebook
Oh, yes.
And what you ask your follow-up question to ask what do you see as
the future and attention flow?
Versus Supply tools and we'll tensorflow go
that we have Angry all this is a very good question.
I'm going to guess because I really don't know the
answer.
in Academia
pie torch is the dominant Library.
There's a third there's a third.
deep learning library developed by a university in Canada
But I don't remember remember the name.
But yeah, so my politically comes down to tensorflow and
pytorch.
Ron says you can use tensorflow as a backend for pie torch. I
believe well.
I mean you can use them in a change you believe I'm not
sure why we do want to do something like that, but
You know, too I think you're right. It could it could go. I mean
it Google has done this in the past. Google has like a
graveyard of applications.
Google+ was one of them.
polymers another one
This isn't using software development.
Once this tensorflow has distributed processing caps.
Yeah, and what's interesting is if you use Google Cloud.
I think they support pytorch.
I don't remember seeing tensorflow.
in
I think it was complete engine.
Basically, you can really easily deploy a machine learning model to to
Google Cloud.
But yeah, I mean and if machine learning is a
very research oriented field and Pi torch is the predominant Library.
And it's not tied to some Corporation.
I think
it's likely that if I torch does
it.
I think pytorch definitely has a larger community.
but if it doesn't Outlast tensorflow
I think you will continue to remain the most popular.
Library
there is now use tensorflow by the way is because
I learned tensorflow before I work with.
With pytorch and in for pytorch, you
have such a large community. We have all kinds of machine neural
network implementations.
so I can't forecast the future, but my guess is
python should continue to be
more popular
so it might be a better investment for you to
like make yourself every family with pie torch.
I think what a question is, probably Torch versus keros.
Karas is a very
it's more Elementary implementations for new Networks.
So I don't think it's even a competition.
If you want to build serious.
neural network that users convolution recurs and
other types of architectures
Like the one you would say I find in a research paper. You're gonna go
with pytosh. If you're gonna build a very simple like a
toyish model Keras is fine,
like in this example, we're using carrots because it helps us get to the point like understand
the fundamentals.
But if you're doing if you're gonna do any production, I would say pie
torch because you're more likely to find people who know more pytorch.
You're more more electrified people who know pytorch then
tensorflow.
Up. That's what I that's my
answer to you.
another question
any other comments?
How about suggestions for the future? So
I'm in the process by the way of onboarding.
one or two
lectures and physics
I really want us to have physics courses here at Big number as
well.
So if you know if you have a if you have some sort of Interest.
Like there's actually two there's quantitative Finance
or economics to statistics for
finance statistics for economics or Finance.
Mathematical physics. So by the way, a lot of the mathematics and
engineering
comes from physics and it's not easy
to learn these mathematical Concepts outside of the domain of physics.
So we're trying to have a mathematical Physics course. Do you
need any Python tutorial tutors?
That will be also nice. Yes, if you think by the
way if you want to have if you have if there's a topic about what you want to be a speaker.
If you want to give a talk, that's very much. Welcome.
If you want to tutor, that's also welcome. It can
come up with something but even ideas for courses ideas for
open workshops. I welcome those.
But again, if you think about something outside of these, you know
live sessions, I strongly recommend you post them post immune the
channel and I will get back to you.
Okay everybody. So we have one more session. I'll try to make this other
session as more as organized as possible.
But even after that session is over, I'm going to keep on giving you.
More material I think you should have received
an email from Ferry. If you haven't she's gonna keep
sending out emails that this coach is gonna keep getting
updates even after the course is over.
Oh, that's great a great answer. Let's
be in touch. But anyway, even after this
course over I'm Gonna Keep On adding tutorials more notebooks. So
You know you can you should you should have access to those.
Okay everyone until then enjoy your enjoy
your day and I'll see you very soon.
For now. Take care. Bye.